des poupées
qu'est ce qui a encore jean-luc ça va
pas quand j'ai encore avalé de traviole
suroît jean-luc j'ai l'impression moi on
va pas que pour les 30 ans de la fête du
cinéma
trente ans oui grosse fait quoi eh bah
oui mais ça dure 4 jours 3 euros 50 0 ça
me fait plaisir j'adore les faits il
aura ta ta ta ta faim je t'arrête tout
de suite jean luc tu seras sur l'écran
toile mais je veux dire pour une fois je
suis pas en train de me faire fracasser
par un prince charmant
c'est certain bon on enchaîne jolie par
le suprême
enfin cela c'est du béton envoyées
l'accessoire les gars je fais quoi moi
tu souffle les bougies
oui abonnés ah bah ouais bah ouais tout
le monde il m'accuse à tort
s'il vous plaît quand j'étais chaud là
j'ai tout donné
de l'émotion de la présence tout ce à
quoi on parle d'un jusqu'au 29 juin pour
lui apprendre à souffler les bougies les
30 ans de la fête du cinéma c'est du 29
juin ou de juillet 3 euros 50 à ses
rangs si ça va ou
et il ya des cadeaux oui oui oui plein
de cadeaux super jean-luc mais toi tu
touches plus à rien cirque après en
trente ans tu te rends compte
c'est beau d'entretenir la flamme vous
n'avez pas fini de profiter du cinéma du
3 au 9 juillet bnp paribas prolonge la
fête du cinéma
cent cinquante mille contremarque à
3,050 la séance sont à gagner sur
facebook et bnp paribas points à 10 h
cinéma bnp paribas
we love cinéma